[Music]
fusion is the reaction that powers the
Sun and the stars it's the joining
together of the nuclei the very centers
of atoms to make larger nuclei and
release huge amounts of energy
scientists are looking to recreate
fusion on earth because it would be an
incredible energy source it produced no
greenhouse gases no long-lived
radioactive waste and it produces huge
amounts of energy for the weight of fuel
so just one kilogram of fusion fuel
produces as much energy as 10 million
kilograms of fossil fuels fusion only
happens at stellar temperatures so you
need hundreds of millions of degrees for
these particles to come together that's
because the nuclei of atoms are all
positively charged and like charges
repel so in order to get them to fuse
you have to get them moving really fast
so that they slam into each other really
hard and they can get close enough to
fuse you need to heat the gas up so you
need to make a plasma but we still have
huge engineering hurdles to cover before
we can actually make a commercial fusion
power plant you need to have a way of
extracting the energy from the fusion
reaction
and you need to have strong materials
that can withstand the hostile
environment we're trying to make a star
on earth you need to have very very high
temperatures hundreds of millions of
degrees and you need to somehow contain
that plasma and you have to keep it away
from the walls of whatever you're using
to contain it so we use magnetic fields
often in a machine called a tokamak to
trap our hot plasma away from the walls
of the machine and therefore be able to
heat it to stellar temperatures
scientists have been working on fusion
energy since about the late 1940s early
1950s so it's quite a long time now
there are fusion machines all around the
world it's a really international
research project there are lots of
different countries contributing to
ether which is a big machine that's
being built in the South of France it's
a worldwide collaboration but countries
also have their own labs their own
flagship projects so there are there are
numerous tokamaks all around the world
scientists have actually achieved fusion
the jet tokamak in Oxfordshire it made
16 megawatts of fusion power back in
1997 the thing is no one's got more
energy out of the reaction than they put
in so it's gonna be really exciting when
scientists are able to get past energy
break even in the early days I think a
scientist thought that fusion was going
to be easier to achieve than it was
efficient had been quite quickly
commercialized into an energy source and
I think people thought that fusion would
be fairly straightforward as well but
actually it's much more complicated to
get the conditions right for fusion that
makes it inherently a lot safer because
fission has a chain reaction you can
trigger it and it it runs off on its own
which can be tricky
it requires control whereas fusion if
the conditions aren't perfect
when everything stops so that makes it
inherently safe but it also means that
it's very very hard to do
you